madame la ministre de l'outre-mer le 4
octobre 2016
le cyclone matthew passait sur haïti et
détruisait le sud du pays
les dégâts sont considérables avec près
de deux milliers de morts avec un risque
d'épidémie du choléra entre autres
sachant les liens historiques entre la
france et ce pays est dessus ou quoi
entre la martinique la guadeloupe et
sept îles nous sommes interpellés est
très sensibilisé à cette nouvelle
situation de détresse cas prévu l'état
en terme d'intervention et dead de toute
nature eau nourriture vêtements
médicaments assistance sanitaire à ce
million de victimes sinistrés en outre
il y à une forte mobilisation à la
martinique et à la guadeloupe pour
récolter des biens de première nécessité
s'est posée alors la question de
l'acheminement de ces aides des
difficultés sur le sujet étant apparus
madame la ministre
quelles sont aujourd'hui la disposition
réellement prises par l'état pour venir
au secours de ce peuple
une nouvelle fois meurtri et les dons
récoltés en martinique et en guadeloupe
vont ils trouver une aide de l'état pour
être acheminés pour vous répondre la
parole est à mme la ministre d outre-mer
ike à bahreïn
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur en tice
le cyclone matthew a frappé durement
haïti vous l'avez dit faisant un bilan
provisoire
des centaines de morts d'importants
dégâts matériels avant de venir sur le
cas précis de la mobilisation de la
martinique je veux dire la mobilisation
du gouvernement sous l'égide du
ministère des affaires étrangères et par
le biais de son centre de crise et de
soutien qui travaille en étroite
collaboration avec le ministère de la
défense et de l'intérieur le
gouvernement s'est immédiatement
mobilisé un falcon 50 a effectué des
missions de reconnaissance
un premier détachement de 30 personnels
de la sécurité civile est arrivé sur le
terrain de vol
messieurs ont été affrétés pour
transporter 30 militaires
supplémentaires ainsi que près de 70
tonnes d'équipement humanitaire fournie
tant par l'état que par des entreprises
et des ong
notre programme d aide humanitaire à
haïti a également été abondée de 150000
euros au total l'engagement de la france
s'élève à ce stade à 9 164 1000 euros
vous l'avez souligné la martinique mais
aussi la guadeloupe et la guyane
entretiennent des liens forts avec haïti
et les outre-mer pour haïti se sentent
donc solidaire leur population se
mobilise donc pour contribuer à l'effort
humanitaire avec des collectes de dons
et vous avez raison c'est poser la
question de l'acheminement de ces dons
jusqu'à en haïti et après vérification
par le gouvernement haïtien qu'ils
correspondent bien aux besoins qui ont
été identifiés sur le terrain après la
recherche d'une solution de transport
des collectes menée par l' ong urgence
caraïbes et la préfecture mon ministère
a décidé d'agir vite et de contribuer
financièrement à cet acheminement qui
sera effectué par un prestataire privé
j'ai attribué à urgences caraïbes une
aide financière qui permettra l'envoi
d'environ 5 containers ce qui permettra
à monsieur le sénateur effectivement de
faire arriver à destination la
mobilisation de dons des martiniquais
merci j'accueille ainsi vient dames la
ministre sachant que cette situation est
récurrente
il vaudrait mieux prévenir que guérir
la france ne pourrait-elle prendre
l'initiative d'une conférence caribéenne
dont l'objectif serait la mise en place
d'un plan secours internationale face
aux réguliers désastre naturel dans la
région
je pense aux cyclones et aux invasions
de sargasses par exemple chacun serait
alors quoi faire saurait alors quoi
faire avec précision et dans la
meilleure des cohérence et d'efficacité
un dicton bien connu ne dit il pas qu'il
vaut mieux apprendre à pêcher plutôt que
de donner un poisson en aumône merci mon
cher collègue